do you remember ray epps he's one of the
stranger figures from the january 6th
saga
he was the guy who was caught on camera
not only participating in but actually
leading the riot into the
capital
we need to go into the capitol
peacefully
[Applause]
it's pretty weird behavior
a lot of people thought it was weird at
the time you can actually hear them in
the first part of that clip they're
chanting fed fed fed
he's saying go and storm the capitol and
they're saying no don't storm the
capital this guy's a fed don't listen to
him things then got even weirder because
after the riot as federal agents began
locking up midwestern dads and trump
supporting grandmas for getting a little
too rowdy in the capital rotunda
the guy caught on tape inciting the riot
was never arrested
well now things have gotten even weirder
because the new york times has just
published a glowing puff piece on him
the article is by adam goldman who was a
major propagandist for the fbi led
russia hoax now he writes quote ray epps
has suffered enormously in the past 10
months as right-wing media figures and
republican politicians have baselessly
described him as a covert government
agent who helped to instigate the attack
on the capitol last year
he goes on
during the event he was videotaped by a
right-wing provocateur encouraging
people to go inside the capitol on
january 6th in what he described even at
the time as a form of peaceful protest
but what
are they they're defending
according to the new york times
every single person who was anywhere
near the capital on january 6th is an
insurrectionist and a terrorist that
almost overthrew our sacred democracy
except for the guy who incited
the people to go in there he's
apparently a great guy for some reason
and we should all stop calling him a fed
that's what the new york times wants me
to believe
i don't know if reyes is a fed or not
but i do know that a new york times puff
piece is not helping his case right now
go to epicwill.com use code knowles for
all of you adventurous spirits out there
i've got an interesting little tidbit
for you did you know that 100 of people
who skydive will die
did you know that did you know that 100
of people who breathe
will die
it is going to happen baby no one here
gets out alive whether you die jumping
out of an airplane or whether you die
quietly in your sleep 100 years from now
either way
you need to have a will in place and you
need to do it now is a will is the
easiest thing to put off forever until
it's too late but a will is not just
about you it's about your loved ones
it's about the decisions that they will
face if something happens to you it's
about what's going to happen to your
stuff it's about what's going to happen
to your kids it's about what's going to
happen at your funeral you you just need
to get this stuff taken care of be a
responsible adult do the right thing by
your family go to epicwhell.com use
promo code knowles canada l-e-s to save
10 on epic will's complete will package
epic will can set you up with a will in
as little as five minutes super easy
well worth 119 bucks to secure your
family's future without a will you may
as well wrap up all that money and
assets and hand it over to the state
because that is what will happen when
you die no matter where you are in life
you need a will go to epicwheel.com use
code knowles today
the propaganda is going into overdrive
this puff piece on ray epps is
particularly ridiculous from the new
york times it's particularly shameless
that they tell us all for a year and a
half now that anyone who even thought
about going to washington dc at all on
january 6th is a horrible terrorist who
should be sent to gitmo except for the
dude who told everyone to go into the
capital he's a poor put upon man he's a
victim please stop calling him a fed but
it's it's not just on trump it's not
just on january 6th it's not even just
against the republicans you're seeing
this propaganda throughout our political
process especially
when it comes
to covid so dr fauci he's making the
rounds again what did i tell you
you know i hate to say i told you so i
told you when dr fauci went into hiding
coincidentally right around the time
that my documentary faux unmask came out
coincidentally right around the time
that the michael knowles public health
protection pledge was going around
members of congress and the
congressional candidates around the
country all of a sudden dr fauci
disappears from public view i said don't
you think that he's gone forever he is
going to come back they are going to
bring back kovid before the midterm
elections and what do you know
here comes dr fauci
admitting that maybe the vaccines
haven't been totally super duper
effective so far and that's why we've
got another round of covid
there's no doubt that the vaccines
themselves particularly
vaccine plus a booster at the
appropriate time when you become
eligible for a booster
for more than one booster if you're over
50 years old you get eligibility for two
boosters one of the things that's clear
from the data
that even though vaccines because of the
high degree of transmissibility of this
virus
don't protect overly well as it were
against infection
they protect quite well
against severe disease leading to
hospitalization
and death and i believe that's the
reason
neil why at my age
being vaccinated and boosted even though
it didn't protect me against infection i
feel confident that it made a major role
in protecting me from progressing to
severe disease
and that's very likely
why i had a relatively mild course the
vaccines don't work which is why you
need to get more vaccines to protect
yourself against the virus that the
vaccines don't protect you against
overly well
you follow that my head is spinning i
love that
listen here
the vaccines
do not protect against infection overly
well you could drop the overly well they
don't protect against infection
they d it does it
fauci got coveted maxine waters got
covered twice in two months
the
director uh secretary of hhs got coveted
twice in 26 days i believe it was xavier
becerra
a number of other very prominent people
who are vast and boosted
not only are they infected but they get
infected multiple times in a very short
period
of time and so now the propagandists
have to move the goal posts facie says
listen look
the vaccines don't protect overly well
against infection but promise i promise
you right now trust me everybody they
protect really well against it being
worse it's that phrase that everyone has
to recite when they get coveted even
though they're vaccine boosted
they say well yes while i contracted
covet i'm so grateful that i'm vast and
boosted because i know based on nothing
that had i not been vaccine boosted it
would have been so much worse and the
the way that they get away with this is
they pretend that they didn't originally
tell you that the vaccines were going to
stop you from catching kovid they are
memory holding all of those clips i
tried to dig them back up because i
remembered that they talked about that
and i pulled up all my old links that i
had for it the links are dead they have
been burying this thing on the internet
accounts that posted this on social
media they've killed the accounts i had
to go back to an old episode of my show
to find the clips that had previously
been on the internet that had been
scrubbed from the internet in which
fauci and walensky and biden and all of
the rest of them promised you that if
you got the covet vaccine you would not
be infected with the virus
you're okay you're not gonna you're not
gonna get covet if you have these
vaccinations these vaccines are highly
highly effective vaccinated people do
not carry the virus don't get sick
they're really really good against
variants everyone who takes the vaccine
is not just protecting themselves but
reducing their transmission
to other people and allowing society to
get back to normal get your first shot
and when you're due for your second get
your second shot a key goal is to stop
the transmission to get the immunity
levels up so that you get almost no
almost no
infection going on whatsoever when
people are vaccinated they can feel safe
that they are not going to get infected
when people are vaccinated they can feel
safe that they are not going to get
infected what are you talking about we
never told you that the vaccines would
protect against infection
no no that and
liberals
gotta love them
they will tell you with a straight face
the vaccines were never supposed to
protect you against infection no no
oceania was always a war with east asia
they were never supposed to protect you
against infection or transmission the
purpose of the vaccines was always to to
mitigate the risk of hospitalization or
death
what about those clips of wallonski and
biden and fauci all telling you that the
point of the vaccines was to stop you
from infection and that it they would
stop you from being infected with the
virus well those clips are gone other
than on this show i
i challenge you to find those clips
anywhere else on the internet i don't
think you will they're probably going to
scrub this episode because of that
i'm so glad you liked that clip now
here's what i need from you if you
haven't done it already i need you to
ring that bell i need you to ring that
bell because we are very very close to 1
million subscribers and i really want
that gold play button that they're going
to send me they're going to send me the
gold play button and then they're going
to nuke my channel right that's
inevitable but i want the play button
first so make sure you get those
notifications ring that bell ding dong
whatever you got to do we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]